i start really training myself to go to
the studio more i never really know
i i wasn't in it i went in the gym like
that for like you were getting your reps
in hell nah like i was just a regular
[ __ ] doing regular [ __ ] you fam
but [ __ ] i be i ain't gonna lobby on
that type of time now like i love the
studio i don't want to do nothing but be
in that [ __ ] for real like i train
myself like
uh well i say i embrace all the dumb
[ __ ] that happened like
as in like
i embrace all the street [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] that you feel me i embrace
all the cutoffs
i embrace
i embrace like dropping all them weak
ass versus trying to find myself in the
studio um brady saw that [ __ ]
so you feeling me
all i all that [ __ ] did was just make me
wanna you feel me become a better me for
real
so
i i had to train myself like uh i don't
know i wasn't when i was living in l.a i
was i wouldn't live in l.a i living in
glendale i was living in glendale but i
went in my bag i went in my right back
i moved to glendale
a little la area until you feel me stay
focused get away from home you feel me
what year was that
what was that i think
28
18 or 19. so this was like it is 2018
19. this is like peak sob
like 2018 19.
i moved away to get focused and i wasn't
in the studio like that like you feel me
i'm sure i'm thugging with my [ __ ]
like as if i was home i got [ __ ] in
l.a like you feel me i'm kicking it with
them [ __ ] like
just thugging i go to the studio every
now and then by what know that so i'm
like i could do this [ __ ] at home if i'm
beyond this after my son was born
oh no like [ __ ] i just
looked him in his eye one day and like
damn i gotta do this [ __ ] for real like
i just been going crazy ever since
[ __ ] just been in the studio like i
started freestyling and [ __ ] hella [ __ ]
but before i started freestyling
i had to start taking this [ __ ] most
serious i was taking this most serious
in the studio every day and it became
more and more easy to me and once i
started freestyling
it was way more fun to me like when i
was writing that she used to feel like
homework and [ __ ] like
me like it make a [ __ ] not even want to
be in the studio all night if knowing
you got a writing [ __ ] you feel me
once i got comfortable just going in
that [ __ ] and you found punching in
lying back
yeah i got way more fun with this [ __ ]
and it should sound way better like you
feeling me a lot of [ __ ] punch in and
just you feel me just trying to get the
song done quantity over quality my [ __ ]
still quality
my shoot
my other [ __ ] sound like quantity
compared to what i got now and i got and
i made way more songs
this year or whatever you feeling me
like
what i ever been making all the mirrors
like you found me [ __ ] comfortable in
the store